[Music]
[Applause]
in the Oasis main plaza there are a lot
of avatars of random movie characters
wandering about but did you catch John
bender Judd Nelson's character from The
Breakfast Club he's down there it's one
of a few riffs on John Hughes's
memorable detention comedy-drama no one
sir until later references Shermer hi
where the movie was set and during his
rousing final speech pars of all gives
benders same defiant raised fist gesture
side note and get used to these cuz
we're gonna be doing it a lot during
that same rousing speech parse of all
references all the egg hunters or
Gunter's in the gold mines of Gygax this
references Gary Gygax the co-creator of
Dungeons & Dragons alright back to the
movie riffs most people probably get
that the Holy Hand Grenade artifact is
from Monty Python and the Holy Grail but
how about the super-powerful orb of a
Suva that Nolan an IROC used to create a
force field around the final challenge
one clue to its origin may come from the
magic spell that's needed to activate it
anaal nathrakh ruthless bethod dochyel
dyenve nailed it
these words based on Gaelic are the
charm of making spell from the classic
King Arthur movie Excalibur
Wow waited a pander to the Millennials
with your super hip Excalibur references
Steve in another classic movie shout out
one of the foes that the high fibers
face in the first challenge the road
race through Manhattan is King Kong did
you notice that when we first see him
hanging from the Empire State Building
there's a biplane circling around his
head just like the climax of the 1933
original in that same scene parts of all
races in his trusty DeLorean of course
modeled on the time machine from Back to
the Future but did you see that the
front of his car actually has the
recognizable red flashing lights from
Knight Rider that's right he got Kidd
and a flux capacitor installed in that
thing
sight note did you see that Artemis's
bike is from akira pretty cool back to
the future comes up again when Parsifal
uses the artifact known as the Zemeckis
cube which turns back time for one
minute it's named of course for Back to
the Future director Robert Zemeckis who
also helmed notable nerd movies like Who
Framed Roger Rabbit Forrest Gump and
used cars just you know all right just
just rent it when Bob's namesake cube is
you
we hear some elements from the familiar
Back to the Future soundtrack and they
didn't have to make too many calls to
secure those rights Alan Silvestri wrote
the scores for both back to the future
and ready player one screenwriter Zack
Penn also gets a shout out to his own
body of work in there in the background
of Manhattan there's a movie marquee
advertising the film Jack Slater 3 Jack
Slater's Arnold Schwarzenegger fictional
movie star from the alternate reality of
Last Action Hero
that movie was also written by Zack Penn
and it opened on the same weekend as an
iconic summer blockbuster Steven
Spielberg's Jurassic Park ooh sorry
about that Zack but don't feel left out
James camera and you get a reference too
and you'll get a reference everybody
gets a reference when h's Iron Giant
sinks into the lava outside anoraks
Castle she gives the familiar thumbs-up
the same kind that the Terminator gave
John Connor at the end of t2 you also
may have noticed a little tiny almost
unnoticeable reference to one of
Spielberg's favorite director Stanley
Kubrick there's a whole sequence set
inside of one of his iconic films The
Shining remember Steve's film AI that
was based on an idea by Kubrick they've
almost kind of nearly collaborated
before kind of obviously going inside a
movie is kind of a big reference but
there are a lot of clever little nods
hidden within the scenes as well the
theater showing the movie is called the
Overlook which is the name of the hotel
from the movie the sheets of paper with
keys printed on them serving as a
ticking clock still contain the
memorable phrase all work and no play
makes Jack a dull boy if you look
closely at the text and did you notice
that H throws the tennis ball against
the wall angrily just like Jack Torrance
does in the original movie it's true and
Nolan Sorrento's official ioi employee
number 6 5 5 3 2 1 also references a
Kubrick film in a kind of sidelong way
that's the prison idea of Alex de large
from the book a Clockwork Orange
now despite popular demand Steve's never
directed a Star Wars film but he did
manage to sneak in a few little riffs on
his buddy George's creation in addition
to the Millennium Falcon shout out by
Nolan anorak refers to parsable as
is padawan after the first challenge a
term usually reserved for young Jedi's
in training and if you look closely at
weight in Samantha's luxury apartment at
the end there's a little r2d2 hanging
out in the background and as possible
wearing a han Solo belt with a
Thundercats emblem on the buckle I think
he is what do you think speaking of sets
that are overflowing with pop-culture
illusions let's swing by HS garage
there's some fun stuff hanging on these
walls even though the original ready
player one novel is crammed with them
spielberg didn't want to fill the movie
with references to his own films but the
crew still snuck a Raiders of the Lost
Ark poster in the scene there's also a
campaign poster for mayor Goldie Wilson
that's another Back to the Future shout
out and a poster promoting candidate Wil
Wheaton as well the Star Trek The Next
Generation cast member recorded the
audio for the ready player one audiobook
and let me tell you he crushed it cuz
Wesley Crusher that that was his name in
Star Trek let's just move on H also has
Beastmaster and Big Trouble in Little
China posters up but maybe my favorite
bit of obscurity here is that neon
cocktails and dream sign of course
that's from Tom Cruise's classic Days of
Thunder haha no it's from cocktail it's
yeah cocktail pop culture characters
showing up got all the attention and the
RPO marketing but honestly there's just
as much stuff to notice in the
background as there are people monsters
Yoshi's and I don't know whatever wait
has a key man lunchbox in his trailer
and Garbage Pail Kids cards stuck to the
walls the gregarious Games Office has a
framed poster of the classic arcade game
Galaga Ellis eats a tasty sounding
breakfast cereal called glutton nose and
her house is crammed full of snack food
packaging with retro a tee style logos
holidays belt buckle is also the
Thundercats logo and his lapel pin
references the massively frustrating 80s
toy Simon the grenade that Artemus
chucks into the eye of Mechagodzilla is
a mad ball toy even the news clippings
taped up to Wade's wall contain little
jokes and fun details one headline asks
oasis coined the new dollar that's right
you saw a movie containing a bitcoin
reference that happened
eighties music also pops up a lot and
not just when someone throws a zemeckis
cube mrs. Gilmore Wade's friend in the
stacks wears a police synchronicity
shirt in the film's opening scene later
on when Wade first meets Samantha her
tea features the cover artwork from Joy
Division's Unknown Pleasures album when
they meet at the nightclub the robot
bartender is wearing an upside-down
flowerpot hat like the kind worn by the
band Devo when we visit holidays
childhood bedroom he's got a poster
saluting Russia's 2112 album but
slightly more surprising is the fact
that he has a Billy Idol postcard by his
desk at the gregarious games offices
maybe holiday is just a fan but this
could also reference the theme of the
second challenge where players have to
go back and try to fix holidays one
regret from his life the course the
Billy Idol's white wedding tells us that
it's a nice day to start again um sorry
a little section called
these references for things that could
be references or maybe we're just
looking too deeply into this first up
the name Nolan Sorrento this could be a
semi reference or at least an homage to
Nolan Bushnell the engineer and
businessman who started both Atari and
chuck-e-cheese two brands that are
integral to the entire ready player one
a worldview chuck-e-cheese was holidays
favorite restaurant after all also weird
in the opening race through Manhattan a
big lit up sign in the background
advertises Ratner's is this a Brett
Ratner reference arguably the first
Brett Ratner reference in movie history
nope it's not its ratner's famous deli
in new york that closed down quick
question can a special move be
considered an easter egg
because parsable actually uses a pretty
convincing street fighter style hadouken
and his big fight against Sorrento's
avatar that's I mean that's kind of a
reference but also a literal fireball so
kind of right there on the border
finally we hear from Nolan when he calls
in the bombing that Alice's unit number
and the stacks is 56 K like the modem
speed really guys okay this has already
been a ridiculously long laundry list of
Easter eggs and we've barely scratched
the surface but before we go here's some
fun characters to keep an eye out for in
the back
next time you watch the movie in the
distracted globe club look for both
commander Shepherds from Mass Effect
Blanca from Street Fighter Lara Croft
from Tomb Raider Gandalf from Lord of
the Rings and Deathstroke and Harley
Quinn from the world of DC Comics in the
final battle scene look for everyone
from everything but also tracer and
mercy from overwatch Sagat in Chile from
Street Fighter scorpions from centipede
the Battletoads a Big Daddy from
Bioshock spawned Catwoman Deadites from
army of Darkness the Cyclops from 7th
voyage of Sinbad and of course a
predator okay I'm gonna go slam a
Pedialyte and sleep for about 16 hours
because I am spent
see you next time for ready player one
two which is only gonna have the Muppet
Babies in it because they pretty much
used up every other pop culture
reference
[Applause]